Класична оптимізація — ключовий крок у класично-квантових алгоритмах,
таких як варіаційний квантовий власний розв'язувач або квантове машинне навчання.
Проте мінімізувати складні функції
у багатовимірних просторах параметрів часто буває непросто.
Мене звати Вікторія Ліпінська, і в цьому відео ми розглянемо
методи класичної оптимізації для класично-квантових алгоритмів.
Задачі оптимізації — це непросто.
Зі зростанням кількості параметрів зростає й кількість можливих
комбінацій значень — і зростає вона експоненційно.
У шахах, наприклад, є 64 клітинки,
у кожного гравця 16 фігур, і після першого ходу кожного гравця
існує 400 різних позицій. Після двох ходів — 72 084,
після трьох — близько 9 мільйонів, а після
чотирьох — близько 280 мільярдів позицій.
Якщо дійти лише до 40-го ходу, кількість можливих позицій
оцінюється приблизно в десять у ступені 120.
Щоб зіграти ідеальну партію, довелося б перебрати всі можливі
позиції, але через таке колосальне зростання
перебирати їх по одній нереально.
Це можна вирішити, розбивши задачу на дві менші підзадачі.
По-перше, потрібно визначити, які розташування фігур на дошці
імовірно виникнуть у подальшій грі.
Назвемо це нашим підпростором інтересу.
По-друге, вже в межах цього підпростору потрібно визначити найкращий хід.
Назвемо це найкращим ходом.
У цій аналогії початковий пошук по підпростору інтересу
відповідає нашому алгоритму класичної оптимізації.
Щойно цей підпростір інтересу відомий,
квантовий алгоритм зазвичай відповідає за пошук найкращого ходу
в межах цього підпростору.
Почнімо з розгляду лише одного параметра —
тета, що параметризує функцію вартості, яку ми хочемо оптимізувати.
Якщо побудувати графік функції, він може виглядати приблизно так.
По осі X — значення параметра тета,
а по осі Y — функція вартості.
Зверни увагу: функція вартості може бути реальними фінансовими витратами,
які ми прагнемо мінімізувати, або, як це часто буває у варіаційному квантовому
власному розв'язувачі, — енергією, яку мінімізує сама природа.
Наша мета — знайти таке тета,
якому відповідає найменша вартість.
Починаємо з початкового значення тета, і на кожному кроці оптимізації
знаходимо нове тета, яке ще більше зменшує вартість.
Здається, що на графіку одразу видно, в який бік рухатися.
Але складність оптимізації в тому, що насправді ми цього не бачимо.
Ми дізнаємося лише значення вартості — лише крихітний фрагмент загальної картини —
щойно обчислюємо функцію для обраного тета.
Ось як оптимізація працює загалом.
Оптимізатор вибирає значення параметра тета і обчислює вартість.
Як можна здогадатися, довільний вибір тета для відновлення
всієї топології функції — не дуже ефективний підхід.
Натомість розумні оптимізатори на кожному кроці
обчислюють градієнт функції.
Так оптимізатор знає, в якому напрямку на графіку рухатися,
щоб знайти найменшу вартість.
Коли градієнт стає нулем, алгоритм завершує роботу
і мінімум знайдено.
Цей мінімум може бути не глобальним.
Він може виявитися локальним мінімумом —
тобто найменшим значенням функції вартості в околиці,
але не в усьому діапазоні тета.
У випадку одного параметра таке цілком можливо.
Однак що більше параметрів,
то складнішою стає функція.
Вже при двох параметрах ми маємо поверхню,
а при чотирьох її вже навіть не можна намалювати.
Як і у прикладі з шахами, перебір усіх варіантів
швидко стає нездійсненним.
Ми бачимо, що мінімізувати
складні функції у багатовимірних просторах параметрів справді важко.
Але щоб отримати розумні результати, методи класичної оптимізації мають бути
одночасно швидкими й точними.
Вони також мають бути стійкими до шуму,
який суттєво впливатиме на квантові комп'ютери найближчого часу.
Алгоритми класичної оптимізації можна загалом поділити
на два класи: методи прямого пошуку та методи на основі градієнта.
Градієнтні методи потребують інформації про градієнт функції
в процесі оптимізації.
Його можна обчислити аналітично
або апроксимувати методом скінченних різниць.
Методи прямого пошуку не використовують інформацію про градієнт
і застосовують інші стратегії для мінімізації функції вартості.
Серед найпоширеніших алгоритмів оптимізації
у квантових обчисленнях виділяють такі оптимізатори.
COBYLA розшифровується як Constrained Optimization BY Linear Approximation —
це алгоритм оптимізації без використання градієнта.
SLSQP — Sequential Least Squares Programming,
алгоритм оптимізації на основі градієнта.
Він використовує стохастичний вектор збурень,
щоб одночасно обчислити наближений градієнт функції вартості.
У середовищі без шуму такі оптимізатори, як COBYLA
та SLSQP, виявились швидшими за SPSA.
Класичні оптимізатори мають власні параметри,
які можна задавати для конкретних випадків — наприклад, розмір кроку.
Їх зазвичай можна знайти в документації,
що стосується конкретного оптимізатора.
Рекомендую переглянути список посилань нижче, де є порівняння
найактуальніших класичних оптимізаторів.
Розглянемо ще одне явище, пов'язане
з класичною оптимізацією параметризованих квантових circuit.
Як ми вже бачили, зникнення градієнта функції вартості може означати,
що оптимізатор потрапив на плато без цікавих особливостей — так зване
"barren plateau."
Barren plateau може виникати з багатьох причин.
Градієнт функції вартості, що відповідає квантовому circuit
з випадково ініціалізованими параметрами,
спадає експоненційно до нуля зі зростанням кількості qubits.
Це пояснюється тим, що квантовий простір, який досліджує оптимізатор,
стає експоненційно великим зі збільшенням кількості qubits.
Способи подолання цієї проблеми включають зменшення кількості параметрів
і, відповідно, зменшення розмірності базового простору.
Ще один погляд на природу проблеми barren plateau —
задачо-незалежний характер параметризованого circuit
у поєднанні з експоненційно великим простором параметрів.
Проектування circuit із врахуванням специфіки конкретної
задачі може бути гарним рішенням.
Окрім експоненційного простору параметрів, що породжує barren plateaus,
їх можуть спричиняти й інші фізичні явища:
шум і декогеренція в квантових обчислювальних експериментах,
загальна виразність параметризованого circuit,
або нелокальність і ступінь заплутаності функції вартості, що моделюється.
Пошук рішень цих проблем залишається активною сферою досліджень.
Тепер, розглянувши основні компоненти VQE,
у наступному відео ми підсумуємо алгоритм.